hello everyone it's really great to see
you all here um
joining this workshop and the live
session
so this workshop itself is a unique
opportunity and uh one of the reason is
that
because we in this workshop will cover
the introduction to bioinformatics
curriculum
and that is a quite uncomprehensive
curriculum that would involve several
things
so
understanding how it is going to work is
pretty important and very critical to
this training
so we will dedicate a certain amount of
time making sure that you understand the
way
this entire training is structured
including those who have recently joined
i see nivedita here he she recently
joined our research fellowship program
for six months hello nivedita nice to
meet you and i also see a lot of other
participants
from our research fellowship program
like uh dr pradeep is here pia dr priya
is here and it's really great to see you
all
so we
in this workshop will be covering
the overview of bioinformatics
big data bioinformatics and we will also
talk about the application
and we will discuss how chem informatics
is also applied
as a strategy to many
different research problems
so uh this is going to be quite
comprehensive and as you have seen that
we are covering a lot of uh heavy topics
so
obviously we will not be able to go in
depth of all those heavy topics but we
have uh assured that we have all the
get assure we make sure that you you are
getting to learn about all of that
through different resources that we have
put together for yourself
and uh that is something that we are
going to discuss uh in uh this session
as well as uh
throughout the uh workshop we will be
discussing how
uh will be easy to do it how easy it is
to access and do all of this which is
uh quite challenging at the beginning of
uh when we all started with
bioinformatics so it's really nice again
to meet you all and i'm really excited
that you have
you have been able to join the session
and join this workshop and are eager to
learn and apply some of this technology
into your education or into your own uh
research interests
so the first thing i would want to tell
you all is that uh the omics logic
training has certain specific um
goals
for each of you here who are joining so
we have students from high school uh we
have a lot of students doing research in
high school uh for their student
projects and for their uh for to compete
in the different
various scientific fairs and all of that
so uh these students are going through
the same ole miss logic training so one
of the reasons that is being possible is
because of you know preparation of
different kind of materials for
different uh
people from different background
students from different background so
students who are joining from high
school they can expect to be a part of
this international bioinformatics
research community which actually helps
all of us to be connected and help each
other
right
and then we have an pool of experts who
are
experts in biomedical research data
scientists biologists and an opportunity
to interact with them and discuss about
your individual research questions which
is aligned and related to that
as discussed with by sonalika previously
that our research fellowship program is
just
built for that and then developing an
appreciation of data in life sciences
that's kind of very critical to be able
to move forward in this data driven uh
era
where we are understanding that what
data can actually do because uh
something that we usually
don't see
in front of our eyes
as a physical entity but a data is
present in the hard drives that stores
this information and various type of
other devices
so um the actual growth and the effect
of the data is kind of difficult uh to
understand otherwise
but
when you go through uh what it means and
what it holds and
how it can be useful and what it has
been used for and what are the use cases
you will definitely understand that
why uh we are
we are appreciating that more and more
now
again like this all leads to um
participation one of the reasons you
have joined here is that because you
want to learn this and also you want to
showcase that you have been able to
apply this to some of the things that
are important
topics for you
so uh that kind of exposure is required
and that kind of exposure can be
can be gained through such training
uh when i talk about students who are
joining us from their undergraduate
studies and from their master studies it
has been really amazing because
at the time uh when uh the omics logic
platform and bioinformatics was not so
much popular
uh at the time when we were doing our
undergraduates and masters and that's
what i meant
this kind of training was really
difficult because uh the several things
it requires
one
you are doing
you can do a real research that is kind
of really difficult for anyone who is
doing an undergraduate study or a
post-graduate study to go for such um
such
opportunity unless you get to a good lab
unless you've been
getting an opportunity to work in an
industry in an industry as an intern and
all of that are required for us to gain
such experience at an early stage at an
undergraduate stage at a master stage
many of us who have done phd could
imagine that what could it be if we were
doing
and if we were knowing all of this way
before so it actually helps us design
better career for us choose better
career for us or think that what
direction that um i could contribute for
in in this world of science
now uh
the next level there are few levels that
i'm describing here that levels uh that
level advances as our learning advances
and that level advances as we grow from
one stage to another so uh one of the
things that we would want to expect
many of you to accomplish is to be able
to apply complex analytical tools
and do modeling across multiple data
types and why modeling is required
is is kind of
is kind of making sense because when you
have a lot of information when you have
a lot of data when you have a lot of
patterns
so one of the things that biologists or
bioinformaticians would want to do is to
develop prediction models
because when you are going into the
world of unknowns you would want to have
an idea that how can you understand from
the unknowns and that
that could be done by developing
predictive analysis by working on
models by able to do predictions in
simple words that we do all the time for
all of the life purposes
similarly when we do this
there is a need for
there's a need for validation
there's a need for um
uh validation from the community there's
a need for the validation from
scientific from scientists and also to
be able to to replicate something so
that you are for sure that this is
happening the way it is happening
that the way that you are proposing
so um what we are going to learn today
is also helpful in doing reproducible
research which is one of the key agendas
in uh for uh doing
research in today's world
another thing is that uh
that how do we do all of this where do
we get data from and why we are talking
about all of this which would only make
sense if you have that access to such
data
now um let's learn about all of that in
a step wise manner and also let's learn
about how this program and how this
entire um one month experience is
structured because this is a three three
day workshop
and uh we have had uh tremendous uh
information that we got from yesterday's
sessions and those who were not able to
join obviously can join and we learned
about ngs technology one of the key
technologies that is driving the
uh driving the advancements in
healthcare research
how this is useful we learned about the
ngs basics that how data is generated
then we learned about what are the
different clinical application of that
uh sort of data and then we'll learn
about
the
uh the advancement in such as single
cell genomics
so uh
from there
we would want to transverse to why we
are doing this again
so one of the reasons
obviously that we see as a company is a
huge gap
and that gap i think could have
been observed by many of you as well
so this gap is about the understanding
of
data science and biology so many of us
who are really comfortable learning
about different aspects and complexities
in biology
are not so much comfortable when it
comes to you know programming when it
comes to applying data science or do
advanced data analytics
one of the reasons is that
there is a gap
because
for you to learn this multi-disciplinary
field and excel in this
there's a lot of requirement for you to
learn about various things that would
require a lot of hard work a lot of time
maybe phd
so how do we address that gap
we address that gap by
finding
the ways that we can in incorporate
resources and materials
along with our mental guided programs
along with our
t by info platform which is an ai guided
platform that we will explore throughout
this workshop
uh is something that we've been able to
achieve through omixologically
bioinformatics education i'm really
excited that this is working for
a lot of us
and we were able to understand
that how biomedical data or how
biological data
could really change
the way we do research
now there are a few objectives that we
will be uh following uh the goal of this
uh training
is to enable independent research so the
ultimate goal of this training is that
that any all of you here
should be able to conduct your
independent research and that is quite a
difficult thing to achieve
because
scientists all around the world has the
same objective and at a student level
when you're doing your master's when
you're doing your phd when you're doing
your
bachelor's it is kind of challenging
to be able to do this research along
with even your work
so if you're a doctor and you want to do
research because you're generating so
much of data and you can see that these
these um
you can see the patients that how it is
influencing how what kind of drug that
you're using what is what is the effect
and your input is really really
important and that can change a lot of
things for goodwill so one of the
reasons is that
that we do that
along with that i already told you that
this community is something that you
should be able to leverage and now this
community involves a lot of
collaborators around the globe which
means that we have um
scientists from labs
from
cutting edge labs in the us in europe
and many labs in india so you can think
about collaboration and utilizing this
community and then
able to apply that into a real research
work
now um simplifying it is one of the key
reasons that we are doing this session
uh the first session so let's simplify
all of it and what is going to be so you
are going to use uh some of the
resources
these resources are online resources so
you will be able to do everything online
and
if you have a decent internet connection
and a laptop you'll be able to
do
all of the things that we are going to
cover in today's session including high
throughput analysis including molecular
modeling and all of that
so
uh one of the first thing that you did
and i know that all of you have been
added here is on learnomics logic
then in learn obvious logic we what we
are going to do is that it has to be
very clear
to all of you that learn or mix logic is
not just about online courses it is also
about to get hands-on experience
so hands-on experience can be done
through data sets
when you will when you are being able to
apply
these data sets into the into practice
and that's why
this is called omix logic because you
are understanding logic from a
standpoint of data
now
we will be using curated data set for
practice uh in the session
and
before understanding that how it works
it is really important because you will
have access to the learner mix logic for
one month and then there is a
subscription that you can take uh for
ten dollars a month that would enable
you to access all the resources that we
have put together on omixlogic learn now
how this
you know
courses are structured it's kind of
important to understand because unless
you do that you will not be able to make
the most out of the
most out of the courses
and the materials that has been shared
with you which is a key uh part of this
entire training we believe that that is
going to help you a lot
so uh monica uh uh i'm not audible
to you am i audible now am i audible to
everyone else yes doctor mohit your
audible to us
thank you
maybe monika you need to rejoin oh
so yeah that would work for you
all right monika so um going back to the
um the structure of the course so when
you start with the course you will find
that there are terminologies and then
biological context then we are talking
about we are not able to hear you sir
talking about you are audible to us i
can i think monica can reach out
monica can you try to rejoin again
she has not been able to listen maybe
maybe you can ping her
and help her out
okay i mean
let's try do doing that and we are
recording this session so that is also
there so as i was telling you that uh
when you start you go through the
terminologies because uh for anyone who
has who's starting from basics and
for example when you're doing gene
expression analysis and you don't know
what us
splice variants are and many of those
top
biological
uh keywords many of these computational
keywords so it's important to just
understand their meaning so that you can
go forward to the
context and then understanding why we
are doing this for biology and then
coming to the
data formats now data formats are those
are are important to learn because uh it
is like you know converted converting
your biological information into a file
format which is readable by computer so
that is uh the data format and then the
analysis of
an
analysis logic that why we are doing
this
along with that obviously
it is kind of an interactive place so
there is uh concept mapping there is
question analysis and then there is
functional linkage
by using quizzes and understanding that
how it binds together
now the projects
so here in projects you will find
research examples so there's a
discrimination or differentiation
between uh courses and
projects which are bundled uh placed
together in the courses tab on
learnomicslogic once you do the course
you have to start first with the course
and then you have to move to the project
so you do a course on genomics and then
you do a project on
sas go to would make sense because you
have learned about the technology now
you're learning about the application
similarly when you are doing um
transcriptomics the next thing that you
can try to do is maybe a project on
modeling precision modeling uh precision
medicine or
the mouse pdx model uh mouse pdx project
because that talks about a different
type of omics data and how it could be
integrated and why and how
transcriptomics data is used in such
projects so we will cover all of that in
today's session nothing to be worried
about we are just going for a quick
overview so that you understand that how
this entire thing is structured and
could make sense for you to do this
training with us
so
following with that the most interesting
part is the tbi info platform which
enables us to do research by by you know
by using a point-and-click system so the
point-and-click system is built for you
to understand the logic that what uh
application how these algorithms work
what are the different parameters these
algorithms use what are the
logical
flowchart how
one kind of data travels from one
algorithm to another
so that we
we can get the outcome of this complex
analysis so all of that is being
simplified on tbi info platform and
that's one of the key reasons that we
are
using uh tbio for uh our educational
trainings and also for research
now uh all of this is uh appreciable to
the research community because whatever
you're gaining is really important in uh
in understanding of
biomedical or research so your progress
your badges your certification you can
leverage you can showcase to the
community to the world
because this is kind of something that
is
going to be really uh helpful if you are
going to start doing applying research
so um three things
first levenomics logic um
second server t by info
third code playground
so we learned about learnomix logic we
have had some idea about server and then
we are going to learn about the code
playground as well
so bioinformatics in rn python
uh one of the things that we've been
talking about uh to all of you is that
how simply how simple and how easy it is
now um
sometimes it requires you to go for
certain different challenges because you
know that biological data is so complex
and um there is uh always challenges
with integration with understanding that
what kind of data what kind of algorithm
is actually suitable for what kind of uh
kind of data because it because of the
heterogeneosity in this data there is so
much of information and that too is been
spread across different type of data
types now in to be able to do some of
the downstream analysis and if you're
thinking in the context of you know
generating graphs for publication or
presentation doing um
analysis uh
by uh using a machine learning
dimensionality reduction or
applying deep learning so those are the
things that are uh some of the
applications that we have put together
for bioinformatics in r and python and
we also have a
playground
where you can uh actually practice it
all
on the web on a portal sorry on your
browser
you don't need to install r and python
to your local computer and face uh
challenges with library loading and all
of that um but you can do that as well
and we will be able to guide you to be
able to do that after the workshop
during this one month period of time but
in this workshop we are going to use the
code or the code playground and the
snippets that you can see
on the
courses so one of the reasons that we do
this and basically to for you to learn
visualization of you know genomic data
to do exploratory analysis and
hypothetical testing so all the olympics
data
not only genomics but we can do a lot of
exploratory analysis and we can test our
hypothesis when we see patterns in the
data whether the data is following the
trend that we are hypothesizing it to uh
or not
i hope that this whatever i'm discussing
so far is kind of makes sense and
clearly here if not please let me know
so um again um the uh one of the reasons
for uh to simplify uh coding
is using this uh code blocks and using
the tutorials so anyone without a
background of coding can start applying
coding for bioinformatics so it is not a
hardcore coding
course it is a coding for biologists
people who would want to use these um
technology use these languages for their
own analysis not just get you know get
mastered and start developing
applications if you are interested in
developing applications and getting
mastered in r and python there are like
plethora of course courses online that
would supplement in this course for you
to you know to be able to do that